hello people I'm Ryan right
I'm Jerry so we're gonna check out the
trailer to the highly anticipated sequel
yes or prequel I don't know what this is
to Snow White and the Huntsman the
Huntsman winters war Jerry dear Charlize
Theron impression do it you will do this
for me on ceman that's the whole movie
right there there's a lot of that it's
like all of Charlize Theron see I'm
whoa that's gold it's very tell y'all
painful oh it's still ride though
whoever gets in there will be on stove
so it's a prequel
which twice
we have much to do little sister get it
mendler Susteren what it means to be
afraid
we will bring the fear
yes the doors
what are you gonna do take on two evil
sisters in their entire army hey pretty
much
sweet pretty cool that looks rad diggity
it does yeah I mean it's a good trailer
it looks cool for sure it looks like
there's a lot of spectacular [ __ ] to
look at and I really like that Jessica
Chastain gets to just be a badass the
second song in it by returner that on
the radio today I was like that'd be a
great song for a trailer that's why is
it like the movie looks I feel like it
looks like it has more personality and
style than the first one didn't I don't
know if this is the same director I know
that's it looks like it's a cool style
looks like it knows what it wants to be
this time around at least from the
marketing perspective I felt like the
first one kind of would have mixed tones
this one I seem like this is like a
period piece badass action fantasy you
know well that's that's that's what
intrigues and worries me at the same
time because it's like this has become a
genre of sorts it's like okay we're
gonna take a fairy tale but we're gonna
tell a more not grounded but like a more
sort of epic poem version of it where
we're gonna make a grittier and more
violent and a little more down-to-earth
and those movies haven't really seemed
to take off like they're always kind of
in the middle it's like I heard
Maleficent was in the middle hand didn't
do very well know when the Huntsman was
pretty in the middle Alice in Wonderland
was in the middle all these like serious
versions of fairy tales seem to flounder
in the middle I noticed with a lot of
these live adaptations is they're trying
to still honor the Disney movie they
don't really have a Disney movie here to
honor so specifically the other one was
like we want to do our own thing with
Snow White and the Huntsman but we kind
of try to have to throw in some of the
Disney stuff from Snow White so ok those
things are in the original fairy tale
yeah yeah I know I feel but I feel like
with this they're just making it their
own completely with taking some of the
characters yeah making their own story
their own version not basing it off of
like a specific
I just hope it doesn't fall into being
overwrought cuz a lot of these movies
have cool moments have cool scenes have
characters you like but then have a good
20 25 percent of just all the stuff
going on that kind of weighs it down
with being overwrought and a bit too
dark or serious or candy-colored
but you know it's really got me stoked
Jessica Chastain and Emily Blunt in this
same [ __ ] movie oh yeah those are two
of the most badass actresses out there
right now that's part of what makes them
like a sexy actress is because they are
so [ __ ] badass like when they want to
be badass characters well like I said
I'm glad cuz you know I like Jessica
Chastain and the stuff I've seen her and
recently has been either more restrained
or more sort of you know tortured and
this looks like she's actually there so
I kickin some ass exactly and I want to
I want to see her in that type of
relationship or it as opposed to where
Emily Blunt was more likely to get a
role like that especially after films
like edge of tomorrow but now you see
her in this and she's the ice queen so
is this a prequel or a sequel looks like
it's a hybrid I can't tell it's hard to
tell right I'm like wait a minute
first it seems like it's brie how how
Charlize Theron is character came to be
or is she being like resurrect exactly
that's where I'm confused and it seems
like it's a little bit of both I feel
like it's partially telling you know the
prequel story because I always saw that
Snow White and the Huntsman once when I
remember with Chris Hemsworth character
they did say like he has a pass of
working for the Queen and stuff so I
feel like would that be cool to get that
storyline and Chris Hemsworth
I believe actors should transition and
he's done some roles outside of Thor but
yeah yeah that was everyone's favorite
he did rush in the heart of the CV is
looks like it's getting some good
feedback already he's a great actor but
you know everyone only knows him as Thor
these days it's cool to see that like a
good transition I think is given
different characters still give him
action this seems like a good
transitional wolf or any Thorian yeah
but he looks like he does like more
martial arts than Thor stores more about
the hammer and the effects of the hammer
but looks like he's doing some martial
arts you are yeah yeah but I mean that's
what I mean by transition because he's
not he's still immortal he's immortal
taking on yes
something's powerful that's not it's not
the opposite way around he's not a god
this time it's different like like
circumstantial like context stuff but as
like a performance it doesn't strike me
as being entirely different I mean he's
still a bit brash he's got a bit of
humor you know he's still he's maybe a
bit more responsible and self-sufficient
than at least early Thor but they're not
super different I'm interested in seeing
how Charlize Theron and Emily Blunt play
off each other cuz Charlize Theron
didn't really like her in this role I
enjoyed watching her have a reason yeah
well yeah it's like I don't think it's a
bad performance but it is bigger and
more like scene chewing than anybody
yeah because the film had such a serious
tone and she was like I'm in a Disney
yet at issues like I'm gonna go hard
while with this [ __ ] I enjoyed watching
it yet but it is distracting from the
rest of the many effects it's been a few
years and the effects do look better
yeah I mean the effects the first one
we're good I think I just hope this
movie has a better sense for its own
tone and nose to be serious enough but
not to take its story seriously but not
treat itself like it's serious you know
yeah good point
a lot of these movies come across so
clunky because they're like so we're
gonna be serious and then oh and then
we're gonna throw in some
inconsequential humorous dialogue and
move on like I want these kinds of
movies to be better cuz they're all kind
of thing when I compare this I can I'm
crying I'm feeling the same way when I
compare this I'm comparing it to movies
like the Cinderella Abbott a shoe that
[ __ ] the guy didn't yeah which we
actually got great reviews
yeah I did that was good and even though
I'm not thinking like Alice in
Wonderland Snow White and the Huntsman
yeah there have been other one it just
would be nice if you would embrace its
fantasy miss a bit yeah more like I get
it you're trying to take the fantasy and
make it a little more real I don't know
movies full of beautiful people I don't
watch it
these are like celebrities yeah you know
you got why I like the cast man I like
the castle I like the gas to gas you're
talking about I smoke gases or dust I
gotta watch this movie well dudes and
dudettes dudettes if you need to the
channel to click this button above my
head and subscribe to the real rejects
yeah become a real Jeep
reject not a real reject it's become
like a reject catchphrase correct it's
not catch reasons to Jerry dank ass
stubs on this channel hosted by charity
and follow us on Instagram and Vine
mainly we have other social networks
like the Facebook and the Twitter but
Instagram and Vine that's where the
management wants us to be yeah yeah yeah
there's got to be more clever ways to
promote it than being so direct you
could do like a contest a contest what
Lord a giveaway personalized video or
send them a thing or other charge people
for that okay five minutes for me $10
yeah ask me whatever you want I'll show
you whatever you want and you can do it
whatever you want to me is that Shia
LaBeouf